they should fight for pink slips of what
to the [__] company yeah put it
online and we co-headline yeah
[Laughter]
give the company to anyone and they shut
it down yeah no no we put both of our
YouTube channels on the line and we just
exchanged
yeah I'm tired of being me yeah you can
have me so we fight each other we put
our channels on the line we both tap
immediately and we just Swap and then we
swap and delete each other's channels
yeah what happened out there I got
scared I'm afraid no you know me crazy
we beat the [__] out of each other like
even when they go ding ding ding round
over we just keep going and then we
throw in the towel simultaneously and
then our teams each walk out a laptop
and we're holding each other's channels
we delete it live and then they're like
you have you guys wait hold on you have
anything to say we both grabbed the mic
and in unison we're like podcast over
we literally don't do a single piece of
media for the rest of our life yeah we
just go back to writing code